we have a voicemail number 219 uh 2192
david p couple voicemails about the
election also the egg it do we have the
egg man first we'll go without listen to
the egg man hi Dave the other Trump is
president-elect marijuana is legal in
Boston I'm sure you are smoking yourself
silly now yeah of the game ladybug and a
half way on your way to becoming a
full-blown heroin addict sorry Dave
it'll be okay Eggman of course joga he
doesn't believe it is a gateway drug and
no i don't i don't smoke pot so i'm not
but it is interesting that both things
happened one more voicemail here real
quick dative is jeremy nuttall your
coverage of the election was fantastic
and after started looking worse and
worse all i could all i could think was
a man i really wish benjamin dixon
should give me a hug just mmm anyway i
love love everything you guys do that
was a great addition show Pat's
fantastic Rachel we need to see more of
she fill in the hole that was left love
you all alright so a very positive but
appears as as possible yeah the best
four years possible very very nice
voicemail people generally liking
yesterday's election coverage and we
will continue it on today's bonus show
Canada's immigration site crashed during
election night I wonder why that
happened and how did the Voting Rights
Act affect the election those stories
and more on today's bonus show please
sign up support independent media we're
going to need at these next four years
david pakman.com slash membership